much like Lara Jean and Peter's
relationship to all the boys I've loved
before too is going through some changes
not only is John Ambrose McLaren a
recipient of Lara's love letters
becoming a lead character but he's also
getting a brand new face and no we're
not talking about plastic surgery we're
referring to the characters recasting
we've got some plot twists fun facts and
brand new characters to share with you
so stay tuned to find out everything
there is to know about the upcoming
sequel new day menstruation is science
nothing to do with the moon says you dr.
Mann to all the boys I've loved before
was such a massive hit but fans weren't
too surprised to find out that a sequel
was in the works but we have to admit
the way actors nois Antonio and Lana
Condor announced the sequel was a mega
surprise on December 20th 2018 the
actors took to Instagram to confirm the
sequel and their clip had a smiling from
ear-to-ear yes I still love you is set
to come out sometime in 2020 but since
the sequel is in such high demand
Netflix isn't wasting any time so fans
are hopeful that it'll make its grand
appearance in 2019 instead large in
covey and Peter Kavinsky have such an
amazing connection knowing this we were
a little shocked to find out that their
relationship is predicted to waver come
the sequel but let's put these rumors to
rest and find out what's really going on
between everyone's favorite couple
during an interview with today
Lana Condor came clean about what she
believes the sequel is going to cover
she confirmed that a new love interest
is coming Laura jeans way and that
things are going to get a little crazy
it's no secret that fans want Lara Jean
and Peter to continue their epic love
story but John ambrus McLaren is coming
to shake things up in paradise although
the movie will mainly focus on Lara Jean
Peter and John's triangular love affair
Lana also stated that the cubby sisters
are going to get more screen time she
went on to say that the sisters
relationship is the true love story and
that she can't wait to work with her
on-screen family again during an
interview with et director Susan Johnson
stated that the sequel might be hard to
watch due to the many struggles Laura
Jean and Peter will face
although fans are quick to disregard
Ambro
and side with Peter Susan also stated
that Ambrose is so nice
he'll have you questioning your OTP in
no time we don't know about you but we
can't imagine Lara Jean with anyone else
but Peter in fact we're teen Kavinsky
all the way once you're done watching
this video make sure to let us know
whose team you're on in the comment
section for now let's find out which
actors will be reprising their roles in
PS I still love you can you help me
convince LJ to come stay with us
you think I'm risky it's cold outside I
don't do cold we're happy to announce
that the Cubbies are all coming back to
the small screen that's right
Janel Parrish Josh Corbett and Anna Kat
cars are reprising their roles as Margo
dr. Covey and Kitty respectively however
we still know with characters like Jen
Christine and Greg will be gracing us
with their presence but as time goes on
Netflix will reveal more information
about the cast and we'll keep you posted
so make sure to hit that subscribe
button to stay up to date actor jordan
Burchette played the role of John
Ambrose in the first film but he won't
be returning for the sequel in fact a
new face has been cast into the role but
before we tell you which actor is going
up against nois Antonio's Peter Kavinsky
let's find out why Jordan isn't
reprising his role diehard dynam Bros
fans were shocked to find out that
Jordan Burchette was no longer playing
Lara jeans love interest and seeing that
his IMDB page isn't swirling with
conflicting shooting dates were really
not the possibility that he was unable
to reprise his role producer Matt Kaplan
didn't comment on why he chose to recast
Ambrose but indieWIRE had some
assumptions of their own they theorized
that Burchett wasn't the biggest
household name and that casting a more
popular actor would help promote the
sequel some fans are super heartbroken
over the swap that they won't be for
long because let's face it the new John
Ambrose isn't so bad himself so which
actor is going to be taking over
Jordan's role none other than pop singer
Broadway actor and Dancing with the
Stars contestant Jordan Fisher met
Katherine told aw that he couldn't be
more excited to have Jordan Fisher
joined the two all the boy's family
he said that Fischer's career
practically leaps off the screen so if
we didn't know any better
Caplin truly believes that Fisher is the
only actor who can properly emulate and
roses character so let's just call it a
judgement call either sync is little odd
that a man would want to become a
gynecologist
Jordan Fisher isn't the only new actor
he'll be turning up in the sequel by now
there probably aren't a whole lot of
people who don't know the name Ross
Butler the actor rose to fame in 2015
when he played Brett Willis on Disney
Channel's Casey Undercover
he's also well known for playing the
original Reggie mantle on Riverdale
however actors Charles Melton eventually
took over Reggie's role when Ross was
cast as AK Dempsey and 13 reasons why
all in all Ross Butler is a diamond in
the rough and we can't wait to see what
he brings to the sequel he's set to play
trevor pike who's known as Peters best
friend Matt Kaplan told aw that everyone
is thrilled that the endlessly charming
Ross Butler has joined to the cast were
super excited to see Peter and his BFF
Trevor growing it out on screen but wait
there's more to this story than meets
the eye Noah Santonio and Ross Butler
are best friends in real life so expect
to see a lot of chemistry between Peter
and Trevor believe it or not but Noah
and Ross have been friends since they
were young they're clearly comfortable
with each other we mean just look at
this picture
there's some serious bonding going on
we're happy to hear that Peter will have
a shoulder to lean on when things
between him and Lara Jean start to get a
little shaky
their friendship will surely reach new
heights once they've finished filming
the highly anticipated sequel fans can
hardly wait for 2020 to roll around they
want PS I still love you and they want
it now in the meantime let's entertain
ourselves by taking a vote so whose team
are you on Team Kavinsky or team Ambrose
let us know in the comments section and
at the same time tell us how you feel
about Ross Butler joining the production
and that's a wrap don't forget to like
this video and subscribe to the things
thanks for watching we'll catch you next
time
[Music]